[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
j'ai eu la chance de grandir dans une
famille proche de la nature et grâce à
ça j'ai été sensibilisée à tout ce qui
touche à l'environnement
j'ai développé un respect pour le vivant
il ya d'ailleurs se souvenir qui me
reste de mon enfance c'est celui du
noyer au fond de notre jardin en
normandie et environ une dizaine
d'années il a été largué très sévèrement
presque complètement décapité et pour le
faire repartir
ma mère l'a enlacé et lui a parlé
presque tous les jours pendant un an
aujourd'hui il est magnifique et nous
donne des noix délicieuse un petit peu
plus tard vers 15 ans j'ai découvert ce
qu'était le consumérisme un de mes
professeurs nous a fait étudier le
consumérisme aux états unis et plus
généralement les modes de gestion et de
vie liée à la consommation
c'est là que j'ai découvert qu'on est
sur une planète que l'on exploite de
façon linéaire alors qu'elle fonctionne
de façon circulaire
ça veut dire qu'on est dans un système
qui tarde et les ressources et qui ne
pourra pas durer alors ce sujet là m'a
vraiment touché m'a marqué et j'ai
décidé de le développer un petit peu
plus pendant mes études pour ça j'ai lu
des deux j'ai lu des articles
j'ai lu des livres j'ai vu des
documentaires et j'ai compris que nous
sommes actuellement au sein d'une crise
climatique et environnemental indéniable
savez-vous d'ailleurs quel est le
pourcentage d'animaux sauvages qui a
disparu de la surface de la terre ces
quarante dernières années 20 % 30 % 50
60 % 60 % des animaux sauvages présents
sur terre ont disparu ces quarante
dernières années
vous vous rendez compte de l'impact qu'a
notre façon de consommer sur la
biodiversité c'est effrayant mais grâce
à ces d'héritage familial et à ses
découvertes lors de mes études
il y avait comme une petite voix au fond
de moi qui m'incitait à faire quelque
chose je pouvais pas rester là les bras
croisés
donc j'ai décidé de passer à l'action en
janvier dernier je suis partie au
cambodge
alors le cambodge c'est un pays
magnifique mais puisqu'une image vaut
mille mots je vais tout de suite vous
montrer le problème majeur là bas le
plastique jetable est présent partout
savez-vous d'ailleurs que cette photo-là
a été prise dans une zone classée
écotouristique l'écotourisme saison sa
définition c'est un tourisme qui est
respectueux de l'environnement c'est un
tourisme qui contribuent au bien-être
des populations locales
je vous laisse juge du bien-être que
cela peut apporter aux populations
locales
alors sur place mon travail et c'est est
de développer un programme et une
formation qui permettent aux entreprises
de l'industrie du place de l'industrie
du tourisme de ne plus utiliser ce
plastique jetables alors évidemment on a
fait face à des défis matériel à des
défis financiers
mais vous savez ce qui m'a le plus
marqué c'est que lors d'une formation
des khmers nous avoue qu'il pensait que
le plastique et plus généralement les
sacs plastiques venait des arbres alors
ça peut paraître surprenant comme
remarque
mais il ya vraiment une logique derrière
tout ça puisque avant l'arrivée massive
du plastique dans le pays dans les
années 80 environ
les habitants utilisaient d'autres
choses pour emballer leur nourriture
leur aliment par exemple des feuilles de
bananier alors une fois qu'ils avaient
consommé leurs aliments il prenait la
feuille de banane et l'a jeté dans la
nature à la première grosse pluie ça se
décomposait et on n'entendait plus
parler
sauf qu'évidemment avec le plastique ça
ne fonctionne pas pareil
ensuite sachant que le plastique est
issu de l'industrie pétrochimique
évidemment les khmers sont les premiers
sur place à se relever les manches et
essayer de mettre fin ce problème là
c'est d'ailleurs pour ça que de plus en
plus d'associations secret sur place
pour nettoyer les rivières nettoyer les
villes
si je suis tout à fait honnête avec vous
à ce moment là ça a été très difficile
de garder foi en mes idéaux et en mes
valeurs je me suis sentie complètement
impuissante par rapport à la charge de
travail qui avait sur place
j'avais complètement sous-estimé ça et
je me suis dit qu'en fait il aurait
fallu tout réformer repenser l'éducation
repenser le système au complet et moi en
tant qu'individu seul je voyais pas ce
que je pouvais faire
alors en rentrant dans le secteur du
développement durable j'ai rencontré sur
place des dizaines de jeunes qui
s'engagent au quotidien
certains de nos amis avaient créé une
entreprise qui vendait des pailles en
bambou comme alternative aux pailles en
plastique
j'ai rencontré des étudiants d'écoles
d'ingénieurs qui étaient sur place pour
créer des mini station d'épuration ou
encore des réseaux d'électricité liées à
l'énergie solaire donc des super projet
et c'est vraiment en voyant l'engouement
des jeunes sur place et leur engagement
celui des khmers et des étrangers dans
le pays
dans le secteur du développement durable
que je me suis accrochée et ici aussi en
france la jeunesse propose des solutions
pertinentes
il faut savoir que notre génération à
trois grands atouts tout d'abord nous
avons des facilités de communication
grâce aux médias sociaux
ensuite nous avons une grande diversité
culturelle enfin nous avons des idées et
des opinions novatrice et c'est grâce à
ces trois facteurs la cause aujourd'hui
on peut voir fleurir de nombreuses
initiatives en france et aujourd'hui
j'aimerais vous parler de cinq d'entre
elles en particulier qui me tiennent
vraiment à coeur la première c'est la
communauté la fourmilière à paris alors
cette communauté vous permet de
participer à des benêts des bénévolat
fun et variés en tout genre ils ont
décidé de créer leur communauté autour
de deux principes clés le partage et
l'amitié
ça veut dire que si vous allez à leur
événement vous êtes sûr de bien vous
marrer et de repartir avec de nouveaux
amis leur credo rendre le bénévolat
aussi fun et accessible qui inverse
entre potes
donc là je pense que vous avez saisi
l'ambiance d'ailleurs sur cette photo
ils sont en train de célébrer les deux
ans de la fourmilière dans un caveau
parisien donc voilà c'est super
décontracté super festif
leur but c'est de vous mettre en contact
avec des associations qui ont plein de
missions différentes
vous pouvez par exemple lutter contre le
gaspillage alimentaire distribuée du
vêtement faire du jardinage et plein de
trucs super sympa maintenant pour les
sportifs parmi nous est ce que vous
connaissez le blogging à leurs plugins
c'est la contraction de jogging et de
plots cas hop qui veut dire ramassés en
suédois c'est un jogging au cours duquel
on ramasse les déchets sur son chemin
fallait y penser
ça veut dire que vous courrez vous
faites vos joggings vous faites des
squats pour ramasser les déchets sur
votre chemin vous nettoyer la nature et
ça économise un abonnement en salle de
sport donc c'est une solution pertinente
la troisième solution de j'aimerais vous
parler est liée aux réseaux sociaux et
plus particulièrement aux youtuber et
aux influenceurs qui nous encouragent au
quotidien en ce moment au mois de
novembre
il ya un site internet qui s'appelle on
est prêt point fr peut-être que certains
d'entre vous en ont déjà entendu parler
alors autour de ce projet c'est plus de
60 youtuber français qui avec leur
communauté ont décidé de réaliser un
défi par jour pendant un mois pour le
climat j'aimerais d'ailleurs cité
l'humoriste swan périssaient qui a
déclaré lors d'une interview pour le
journal le monde
c'est notre rôle de montrer l'exemple
on peut utiliser notre influence pour
autre chose que faire rire émouvoir ou
raconter des histoires et c'est ça qui
est intéressant c'est de voir que
aujourd'hui ce qui touche à
l'environnement
ça devient accessible on arrête de nous
lister des chiffres alarmistes
on arrête de nous montrer des images des
photos d'il à l'autre bout de la planète
qui sont submergés par le niveau des
océans
aujourd'hui grâce aux mots réseaux
sociaux qui ont quand même un but
divertissant qui ont un but
sociabilisant
on est sensibilisé on est motivé pour
changer notre façon d'agir et de
consommer d'ailleurs pas plus tard qu'il
ya trois semaines c'est exactement ce
qu'avait fait les youtuber mcfly et
carlito pour ceux qui les connaissent en
organisant une clinique un dimanche
après-midi alors ils ont fait appel à
leur communauté pour nettoyer les rues
de paris pendant 3h30 et l'événement a
été un succès majeur
alors moi ce qui m'a marqué dans leur
vidéo c'est premièrement l'engouement
des jeunes qui ont participé à cet
événement je le rappelle sortir de chez
soi un dimanche après midi pour aller
nettoyer les rues de paris
c'est quand même pas rien et
deuxièmement c'est la tranche d'âge qui
est des jeunes qui ont participé à cet
événement
je dirais que la grande majorité avaient
entre 10 et 15 ans donc là clairement
nous on n'a plus aucune excuse
cette vidéo est cet événement montre
aussi que les communautés virtuelles
peuvent se retrouver dans la vraie vie
pour avoir un impact positif sur la
société
enfin la dernière initiative
ce sont les éco école alors comme vous
pouvez le voir sur leur site internet
sont des écoles qui vont proposer des
programmes de développement durable pour
des établissements allant de la
maternelle au lycée
et cette fois c'est très fort parce que
ça veut dire que dès 3 ans on peut faire
en sorte qu'un enfant agissent on peut
faire en sorte qu'un enfant soit
sensibilisé ça franchement je trouve ça
très inspirant pour pour l'avenir et
c'est grâce à ces exemples-là et de
nombreux autres que j'ai aussi foi en
notre jeunesse est en notre génération
il faut savoir qu évidemment notre
génération ne s'engagent plus sur les
mêmes thématiques que celle de nos
parents c'est d'ailleurs ce que montre
une étude qui a été menée par le cne ce
qu en septembre dernier qui dit que les
jeunes préfèrent le bénévolat à la
politique aujourd'hui
ça veut surtout pas dire que les jeunes
ne s'intéressent pas à la vie civique
puisque près de la moitié des lycéens
français sont
engagé dans une association humanitaire
ou environnementale et j'irai même plus
loin en disant que la france est le
deuxième pays d'europe en termes de taux
d'engagement des jeunes adultes ça veut
dire qu'on est l'un des pays où il ya le
plus de jeunes adultes qui font du
bénévolat ça c'est super c'est vrai que
cette étude
elle montre aussi une crise de confiance
entre la jeunesse et l'institution
politique aujourd'hui de plus en plus de
jeunes comprennent que le véritable
changement viendra grâce à eux par des
petits gestes au quotidien
c'est ce qui permettra de faire un
changement durable ça nous ramène à la
légende du colibri dont nous parle
pierre rabhi chacun doit faire sa part
aujourd'hui je pense que notre
génération est différente de celle de
mai 68 puisque on traite les problèmes
qui sont les nôtres d'une manière non
violente et j'irai presque même jusqu'à
dire d'une manière bienveillante
on parle d'ailleurs de transition
écologique
on ne parle pas de révolution écologique
aujourd'hui on assiste un changement
structurel de la société et non plus en
changements conjoncturels
enfin s'il ne devait y avoir qu'une
seule chose à retenir pour vous de ce
taux que j'aimerais que ce soit le fait
que nous la jeunesse
nous avons un véritable potentiel une
force d'action et un pouvoir entre nos
mains avec l'immédiateté de
l'information avec tout ce qu'on sait
aujourd'hui on peut plus permettre
d'être ignorants il faut retirer nos
oeillères et cessé d'être spectateurs
dans le désastre écologique que l'on vit
si on reste spectateur c'est un
comportement qui est complètement
inhumain inhumains au sens propre et au
sens figuré puisque nous sommes à un
moment de l'humanité où l'homme doit
prouver qu'il est capable d'évoluer
je tiens d'ailleurs à préciser que c'est
dans les plus grandes crises que l'homme
a été capable de la plus grande
résilience c'est pour ça que j'aimerais
vous quitter
en vous donnant un challenge je vous
défie de faire un geste en accord avec
vos valeurs d'ici la fin de l'année 2018
un geste ou une action que vous ne
faites pas au quotidien et qui aura du
sens pour vous ça pourrait être allé une
marche pour le climat participer à un
atelier de végétalisation d'une rue de
paris ou encore juste faire un post sur
les réseaux sociaux
vous me direz ça changera pas le monde
du jour au lendemain d'accord mais ça
pourrait être le début d'une évolution
voire peut-être même d'une révolution au
sein de votre vie merci
[Applaudissements]